Daniel how important was that game on
Monday night in in what's gonna play out
this draft and maybe in the next couple
of years in the NFL
am i overstating the importance of it no
you're not overstating it dan if you'll
indulge me for just a second here
because these these Thanksgiving names
as I just have to get a couple off my
channel we've engaged arted somebody who
grew up in San Diego I'll never forget
that 84 homerun hit by Steve gravy to
beat the Cubs that was big out of the
bullpen you can always bring in Craig
there's no food leopards okay kids table
okay especially the yeah but that's
that's not the the litmus test is it's
better than fritzy's like it should be
you step over there hurdle okay so
alright football and as we move forward
Monday night's game means what into the
future of the NFL well I think it's the
exclamation point on what took place in
the Super Bowl last year I thought being
in that in that stadium to watch the
Eagles give up six hundred yards and
still win a Super Bowl that that was
definitely a something that was going to
be felt in a big way in the personnel
room and I think that game where
everybody was watching last night was
kind of the exclamation point and I
tweeted out after the game you know this
is a bad day to be a run stuffing
defensive tackle that's entering into
the draft because you watched that game
last night and I think we would all
agree you've got top five quarterbacks
but you also had arguably the the best
running back in the NFL and Todd Gurley
and you look at the way that game went
they decided to give type early 12
carries they gave Kareem Hunt 14 carries
mahomes through it 46 times and gone
through 49 times so if you're drafting
defensive linemen do you want him to
have an impact on the 49 pass plays
throughout the 12 run plays so you know
like I was involved when we drafted
Haloti not one of my favorite players
I've ever scouted was a great player for
our team there
right now in the current climate he I
don't think he would be a first-round
pick because if you can't get to the
quarterback your value is so greatly
diminished and that goes to a bunch of
different positions as well you need
playmakers on offense you need on
defense again defensive lineman you got
to have to pass rushers and then outside
of those pass rushers you need some guys
that can just make plays you're gonna
give up you know give up a 20-yard run
here there who cares who can generate a
turnover so that's kind of where
everything's headed but I also wonder I
feel like you can scheme on offense but
you have to have players on defense you
have to have speed you have to have
speed on defense I mean if you look at
the bad defense it seems then they are
slow-mo camera and four or five flat
coming out of Eastern Washington he made
two huge plays in that game Aaron Don
around 465 obviously we know how great
he is but you have to be dynamic and
fast on defense and you sacrifice a
little bit of size no question
offensively I do think coaching wise
scheme is huge you know it's like that
goes back to the old Bill Walsh way of
building a team which is all spending
all my first-round picks on defensive
players because you got to have the
athletes on that side of the ball where
I can work around my scheme a little bit
on offense yeah I truly believe that but
if I said you could have to start your
team Aaron Donald or Todd Gurley I would
take Aaron Donald again I love Todd
Gurley but I just think in a passing
league and finding interior pass rushers
is probably the toughest thing to find
outside you know cackles right now is
darn near impossible because of the way
the college game has been played you
were just not seeing a lot of good
offensive tackles end of the week but
interior pass rushers is right there so
I would go into your pass rusher I mean
you watch that game I mean Todd Gurley
is better than Korean haunt no question
but cream hunts are really good players
I got him in the third round so I'll pay
the premium and I'll take the interior
pass rusher if you have the NFL and they
sort of piggyback or adopt a lot of
things they see in the college ranks the
the best teams in college football will
certainly Alabama you know you don't
have NFL teams trying to emulate what we
see with Alabama used to be that was the
style you had you had a great running
attack your pastor through you know 15
to 20 times and then you had a great
defense will we see defense win
championships again I can be really hard
when you look at the rules the way they
are it's just so heavily slanted towards
the offense so I you know I think you'll
see teams with with great defensive
players it's just going to be hard to
keep anybody in check the way
everything's set up right now it's just
all steered towards the offense and I
think you can even just look at the pass
interference penalty you know the
difference in that from the college game
the NFL game is so huge do you think
that was the Whitsun one rule change
though that has brought us to this
scoring output well I think the two I
think the two big ones and obviously
ones not recent but just the way they
crack down on illegal contact and
holding on the DBS beyond five yards
where you can't touch anybody that's
made it darn near impossible for them
that's huge and then I think you know
for the safety of the game but taking
away the head shots over the middle of
the field there's nothing to discourage
you from working in the middle of the
field so you can take you start to be
able to take small bodies and work the
middle of the field is you just wouldn't
survive and now you can take your
speedsters you can run behind then you
can also run them in the middle of the
field because there's no threat they're
gonna get hit or hurt he's Daniel
Jeremiah NFL Network analyst former NFL
scout joining a Stan Patrick show but I
I look at Patrick mahomes you know you
had these mock drafts and I love them
but I hate them because I don't think
they mean anything right now and then
all of a sudden you know Patrick mahomes
jumps up
deshaun Watson jumps up where is if you
looked at the mock drafts
I mean Christian Hackenberg would have
been the number one pick after his
freshman year if he could have come out
at Penn State so at what point do you
start to assess these mock drafts and
say okay now you're seeing something
that is real as as opposed to somebody
who's just analyzing this from afar well
I have to do I think five of them a year
and the first one is
it's always right after the junior
declare date so it's like January 14th
so I do five of them the fifth of which
is I do the night before the draft so
don't tell anybody but I probably
wouldn't read anything that any of them
until the wine the night before the
draft is this a good quarterback dress
you know we'll see who all comes out I
don't think it's gonna stack up with
what we've had in the last couple years
so you know look I've got a lot more
work to do on these guys but usually by
this time I've seen enough with some
guys but I'm like man okay I'm fired
I can't necessarily say that at this
point in time but you know I haven't
done my deep deep dive yet but we're
also in you know on display on Monday
night yet Aaron Donald who was just
unbelievable he was projected to be a
third or fourth round pick until he went
to the combine Patrick mahomes people
thought a fun guy you know I got Favre
like qualities little bit low gambler
they're risk taker but takes too many
risk and he played in the big 12 we
don't know how good he's gonna like how
did how did this Scout how did people
miss how did teams miss on Aaron Donald
and Patrick mahomes well you know look
Aaron Donald I think was just a question
of okay is it you know his size was a
concern you know even though he was at
he was at Pitt it wasn't like he was
that you know Alabama so some concern
there I mean I think I had him early on
in the process in the late 20s and then
he ended up climbing way up from there
but you know now he's kind of the
trendsetter for for being you know that
body type and being his dominance he was
and then it was you couldn't deny when
he's tested you just saw how
ridiculously explosive he was was like
okay you can't penalize this guy anymore
for his size with mahomes mahomes had
tremendous ability but he was so raw and
I mean he's been phenomenal and I think
there's obviously with his talent he
could have gone in different places done
well but I think with his talent coupled
you know with Andy Reid and what they
have in place there I think that was the
couldn't go into a better place
I mean I've seen Andy Reid haven't
worked with him before Dana I've seen
him take you know those cars like you
drive around and see somebody that's
just taking like a Mercedes symbol and
they've slapped it on a little people
car you know it's not a Mercedes I think
they just did well this was this was not
that situation I think
with other quarterbacks like Kevin cloud
this was a sports car that just needed
to be you know washed and cleaned up and
it's it's sparkling right now
I wonder if and I I tell people when you
look at these quarterbacks it can be
very tenuous that do you have the same
offensive coordinator what you have an
offensive minded head coach what kind of
weapons do you have how good is your
offensive line so I could look at Josh
Allen and I don't know if I put Patrick
mahomes in Buffalo what is he doing in
Buffalo or if I put him in Cleveland
what's he going in Cleveland if I said
Baker Mayfield is gonna be in Kansas
City like you have to have those
elements I got Andy Reed a brilliant
offensive mind I got a good offensive
line and I got unbelievable weapons as
well and you had a year to sit behind
Alex Smith so I think it's it's a great
formula when you're looking for success
and man mahomes has been great but I
think that he had the pieces in place
there to give him a head start I agree
with you completely and in the the
situation absolutely matters and you
know again I look at all the
quarterbacks Andy Reid has got to play
well and I can't tell you a quarterback
he's had that hasn't played well and
then you take somebody with with just
super you know incredible raw ability
that's why you're getting the the crazy
numbers that were that we're seeing
right now but trust me when you're a
scout there are certain positions when
you're in that when you're in the room
and you have maybe a lower grade on
somebody like it for me it was the Colts
so if I had given the Colts if I'd given
offensive linemen a free-agent grade and
also and the Colts took him in the
fourth round with Peyton Manning and I
just got crap I'm gonna have to hear
about this from my GM like this guy
started for the Colts for six years and
I'm like yeah man he could take five
guys he's blocked from here and make him
look good as an offensive wife he makes
all the calls he gets the ball in his
hands in one second if we dress like I
would've been a disaster but that's kind
of like what Andy Reid when you give him
a quarterback you know they're gonna
they're gonna work who's the one player
that you just wish you could have gotten
that you didn't drive Oh for me it's
it's it's Bob Sanders you know you
remember Bob Sanders in the Colts we
think about how those Baltimore defenses
were and we we were on the phone as he
was on the phone
trying
trade up to get Bob standards we already
had ed read and we're gonna pair him
with Bob Sanders and so we're on the
phone with the Colts to trade up and
they said ok if our guys not there we'll
trade with you and so we just kept
talking to him and talking to him and
talking to him finally they're on the
clock all right we got a deal he goes no
our guys still there and he goes who's
your guy if I said you could only have
ed Reed or Ray Lewis to start your
defense oh man I would say this I will
put it this way this is as political as
I can get
Henry is a favorite player I've ever
been around and I would I would take
great Louis okay hey so does that get me
out of trouble
yeah well you only have to worry about
Ed I mean I mean but but but Ray just
from a leadership standpoint and what he
got out of everybody else and we would
be in the draft room and we were talking
about a player and we'd say okay he's a
unbelievably talented but you know he
doesn't play that hard and we say it
doesn't matter rail they complain you
know we can we could we can dress those
guys great won't allow it
yeah that was a huge I mean that was a
huge benefit to have him there hey
thanks for joining us as always happy
Thanksgiving and Thank You Daniel that's
a Daniel Jeremiah for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]